welcome all of you here today for this
especially web on New York City and
electric car our school is pleased to
host this panel of distinguished aspects
we are taught leaders in those fields
judging the discussion today are young
Gilbert the term a secretary by spacing
of reading management a keynote speaker
and our families are Jeffrey Sachs
director of Columbia Earth Institute
Roger Anderson Doherty senior scholar at
Columbia lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory Norris burns director of
sustainability sustainable mobility at
the agency to turn APIs wats General
Motors representative for the cherry
bowl and add to crescent director of
research and development at con Edison
the moderator for today's panel is
cuddling the banner that with the editor
and global business editor of Newsweek
magazine and a horse is dead waltz
director of our Center for computational
learning system it is similarly
appropriate that this discussion is
hosted by columbia engineering whose
mission is to educate socially
responsible engineering and applied
science leaders whose work resolves in
the betterment of the
human condition locally nationally and
global amended our faculty members to do
work or intensive in a different tiers
in areas such as sexors bioengineering
and nanotechnology what I call cyber
biophysical systems the place where the
biological the physical and the data
refuse advances in this area will
develop technology that will
successfully address key challenges in
health sustainability that might be in
water energy or climate and in
infrastructure whether it is physical or
digital today's panel discussion
actually we will touch a lot of these
trees history research areas health in
future academic and industry leaders our
faculty is ahead of the curve working on
the frontiers of knowledge and in the
application of that knowledge yesterday
on earth day we host an event smarter
students for a smarter planet the focus
was on combining IBM's technology
resources and columbia academic programs
specifically engineering alongside
science business and law to prepare
students to enter a job market that is
looking for engineers and apply
scientists to create more sustainable
buildings electric grids and
transportation today this panel will be
specifically addressing the issue of the
smart grid and electric car I want to
thank each of the panelists for
participating in this important
discussion on the future of private
transportation in New York and all other
major metropolitan areas in this country
at this time I would like to introduce
the house of today event the big walls
who will introduce each one of the
keynote speakers and panelists David's
director of the Center for computational
learning system the center is a world
leader in machine learning and data
mining research with a focus on the
application of this research to specific
real-world challenges a Monday and
electric power grid Dave leads a group
of researchers again smart grid
technology who are working closely with
both Kong Edison and the US Department
of Energy dave has served as president
of the Americans
sociation for artificial intelligence
and is a fellow of the Association for
Computing Machinery he is a member of
several government and academic advisory
boards as well as the NSF computer
science advisory board please welcome
David walls thanks Fanny and good
morning everybody I'm very pleased to be
part of this exciting event and I think
historic event I've been a car lover as
long as I can remember when I was 11 my
grandfather taught me to drive his 1931
ford model a truck which had been
shortened to serve as a tractor in his
farm in Maine and throughout the 50s by
friends and I eagerly anticipated every
new radically different car model and
looked for them on the road as they
arrived we drew and shared pictures of
our fantasy vehicles and I lobby my
parents to get the flashiest and most
powerful models I could do without huge
success but better than what they would
have bought themselves all this time I
also read futuristic articles about
electric cars in popular science and
Popular Mechanics and you know this
seemed like an exciting future as well
as an exciting pests maybe 110 years ago
there were electric cars but but they
were gone by the time I was a kid for
sure the first car I owned was a 19 65
Mustang sorry GM but my uncle was a Ford
dealer so we were sort of word family I
personally added Carroll Shelby
aftermarket modifications to it highrise
aluminum manifold holley four-barrel
carburetor free flow exhaust system and
manifolds and the body stiffening and
suspension modifications with the help
of some professionals over the next
three decades I owned mostly a
succession of family haulers not not so
fast anymore and over that period we've
seen an amazing
improvement in engine efficiency due
primarily I think to information
technology like electronic control of
everything as well as simulation and
optimization of all designs but despite
the two major oil shocks we've had
during that time and wide publicity
about the role of cars in global climate
change most of the increases in engine
efficiency of God to make the cars more
powerful and only secondarily to improve
engine efficiency energy usage rather as
a side note it interestingly I think
most today most family sedans would
handily outperform my customized Mustang
which is kind of amazing but they only
get modestly a better gas mileage only
during the past decade if we really
started to see change with the
introduction of hybrids but even till
today electric cars have remained
perpetually futuristic well today that
future is finally here with the
impending introduction of the Volt our
focus for today and I think more widely
we are on the verge of a really
remarkable era of automotive innovation
we have a great panel today to discuss
that we have a chance to learn about
what's happening and what's coming from
a number of the key innovators in this
in this area and we'll also hear about
the effects issues and challenges raised
by these technologies so I'm very
pleased to introduce our first speaker a
keynote speaker which is job John
Gilbert John is the second vice
president and coo for the Rudin
organization Rudin is a very prominent
New York developer that has about 10
million feet of commercial space and 18
apartment buildings before he was a
Troodon management mr. Gilbert was
president of the rent stabilization
Association and he has served in several
capacities for the new york city
government agencies he was appointed one
of the initial members of the New York
State real estate board mr. gilbert's
chaired or co-chaired several task
forces on rebuilding telecom
infrastructure and security and serves
on Mayor Bloomberg's task forces on
energy policy and on improving the
city's emergency response and security
is also on the mayor's new broadband
committee chairs in New York building
Congress Energy Committee and
officer of the grand central partnership
and a trustee of the New York Hall of
Science he's also involved in the VOE
project with coned and in Columbia and
it's my honor to welcome him to give the
keynote John good morning everyone happy
to be here and sorry i delayed everyone
trying to get up here I think today is
is kind of a historic moment because we
we really are at I kind of go back to
1892 and and the chicago world's fair
when much of what we we see today and i
recommend the book devil in the white
city that talks about this but much of
what we know as the modern urban city
today was first disclosed to the world
it was the battle between Tesla and
Edison over alternating and direct
current Tesla won that battle now we
think there's some that think the direct
current should should be brought back
and that's for a later discussion it was
the moment when when Walt Disney's
father first saw ferris wheel and then
ultimately influenced his son to go into
the development of amusement parks it
was all about the distribution of water
distribution of electricity distribution
of natural gas and it's that glimpse
that moment in history that that I think
we're at right now because in my own
vernacular I think it's time that that
mr. Tesla gets introduced to mr. Metcalf
and that the creator of alternating
electricity alternating current
electricity gets introduced to the to
the inventor of Ethernet and that we
create interoperability between those
two networks so that we truly can begin
to influence electrons with photons and
that ultimately off of our blackberries
and off of our iphones we truly can
ultimately make smart decisions about
the purchase of electrons and about the
management
and of our of our electricity
consumption and ultimately our footprint
of carbon the discussion today is really
about electric cars and for us as as
kind of dumb real estate guys we look at
that is how do we make our garages into
charging stations that may sound easy
you know we just create a bunch of plugs
and allow these these cars to plug in
but it's it's it's actually more fun and
more creative than that because as we
really begin to look at these cars as
they're charged and their batteries are
charged that what do we do with that
charge if they pull into our garage is
loaded can we transfer that that that
load to the grid can that can those
electrons be ultimately distributed
elsewhere and then ultimately can we
program those charging devices to
ultimately allow those folks who have
pulled into our garage is to leave when
they want to leave with a full charge
how what influences how does that impact
the grid how does that change that the
load profiles of the grid on a micro
level in terms of that building but
ultimately the overall grid as its
distributed throughout the city very
very important questions and I think
it's it really is that moment we in the
real estate business we have been
struggling with how do we distribute
photons and electrons since the early
90s and clearly it it first was
telecommunications and what we did a
Troodon was to say okay we're we're not
we're not a telecommunications company
but we have to ultimately enable
telecommunication companies to come into
our buildings on a carrier neutral basis
and ultimately distribute those photons
efficiently through the building how do
you do that well we put in cary neutral
risers that ultimately allow three
things to happen and this all happened
out of 55 Broad Street in columbia
university was a was an early partner
with us down
there but carrier-neutral vertical
risers allow the tenants to get multiple
choice of carriers that's a good thing
it allows the carriers to have a just
plug in infrastructure so they don't
have to expend capital dollars that's a
good thing and ultimately it allows the
building owner to sleep at night knowing
that they're never going to have
spaghetti in the vertical risers again
that's a very good thing from my
standpoint so haltom Utley how do we
take those lessons and and transform
that forgive the pun into the electrical
grid and what we see the the challenge
is what is the infrastructure that the
property owner needs to to put into
their buildings to allow that
interoperability that I touched on visa
V the electrical distribution network
and the information technology network
to allow those photons to influence
those electrons and then ultimately how
do we create an environment where
applications once you create that
infrastructure that applications can be
derived and developed by smart Columbia
engineers so that there can be plugged
into that infrastructure that will allow
these buildings and our customers to
make intelligent decisions in terms of
energy consumption management that is
the challenge and I think it's it's a
wonderful challenge it starts in the
basement where we've got a charge and
our garages we've got to charge cars and
it moves right up the rise or right to
the very top of the building in terms of
ultimately where those electrons flow
and whether they're they're intelligent
electrons or whether there's there
they're simply dumb electrons and I
think for us this truly is the the
exciting part of being involved in coned
and do we in terms of of the smart grid
demonstration program I believe this
will change the world as we know it not
dissimilar to the World's Fair of
Chicago in eighteen ninety two we will
very shortly and some of us probably
of us in this room are getting a glimpse
of that right now and the metaphor that
I like to use is a blackberry or an
iPhone and if we take that Blackberry or
iPhone and we envision that as a
building that that network of within
that building we then can begin to try
to develop applications that people will
care about that money where money can be
saved and made and that ultimately our
buildings can be made greener and the
people who work and live in those
buildings can be equipped with the tools
they need ultimately to make intelligent
decisions so that's that's our focus I
should end I could go on for a long time
but I think all of us want to hear what
the panel members have to say I end with
with a little vignette where when I
first met Robert Metcalfe the creator of
ethernet and that we all know Metcalfe's
law that the value of any network
increases exponentially every time you
add another node to that Network it is
not a linear equation it's an
exponential equation and I this was back
well mid 90s where we had just developed
55 Broad Street and it was the world's
first holy wired work environment and it
was bandwidth to the desktop and it was
in a moment of where the internet now we
all take it for granted right we're
really barely existed and it was all
about that first mile it was all about
everybody is saying the last mile the
last mile and we're saying no no no it's
the first mile that the customer is at
the beginning of the network not at the
end of the network and when you think
about first my last mile everything
changes so I met Metcalf and I said dr.
Metcalf I just want you to know that you
know we're going to we're going to
ultimately see if Metcalfe's law works
for real estate and as we connect each
of our buildings with broadband
connectivity and as we put wireless
devices on the rooftop that gives us
parallel wireless networks that
ultimately
we'll survive anything that happens in
the manhole are in the street and as we
by 32 Avenue America's which was the
original ATT long lines building and
transformed that building into a and in
an infrastructure building that
ultimately today is the landing point
for all of the the data that's coming
out of the particle accelerator in
certain Switzerland which then connects
universities like Columbia and other
universities around the United States
having sat in an audience not unlike
this and hearing the the head of Niger
net call 32 of the Americas the
equivalent of the ancient Library of
Alexandria on steroids because of all of
the data that was flowing through that
and metcalf kind of looked at me said
you have real estate networks how's that
going for you and I said well we're
we're not out of the woods yet we
haven't figured it out and it wasn't
until I was literally meeting in a
meeting with already crest nur where it
dawned on me that I wasn't looking at
the network of real estate deep enough I
was thinking about these buildings and
connecting buildings with with fiber and
microwave antennas and but when you
start to think of buildings and the
network of those buildings to include
every single electrical plug that exists
and to identify or to create an IP
address for every one of those
electrical outlets and then surrounding
that with middleware and software that
ultimately can be so that you can use
your mobile device to influence on off
up down whatever is plugged into those
plugs the game changes everything
changes so I would challenge everybody
here today to think about that and to
really think about introducing
Nicola Tesla to Robert Metcalf and to
really think about what that means and
then go back to 1892 and try to envision
yourself walking into that chicago
world's fair and seeing all of this for
the first time everything that we take
for granted the lights the water the air
conditioning the heating none of that
existed and for a moment envision what
that handshake means to each of us as we
try to make our cities and our buildings
and our homes more efficient more
sustainable and more valuable ultimately
so I thank you for the opportunity to
come here today and hope that I've kind
of ignited some some creative thoughts
and really look forward to the panel
thank you very much
okay I think at this time we'll ask
panel to come up on the stage and start
the next phase of this meeting surely do
did that right okay our first speaker on
the panel is Lawrence burns he is
director of the roundtable on
sustainable mobility of the Earth
Institute of Columbia University but he
has many other roles currently he's also
a visiting research professor in
industrial and operational engineering
at the University of Michigan he's
senior advisor to the chairman of hess
corporation he's a contract to the
National Renewable Energy Laboratory a
member of the cleantech Advisory Council
of vantage point venture partners and a
member of the Advisory Council of green
tech capital advisors up until last year
he was a general motors corporate vice
president for research and development
and for planning and strategic planning
reporting to the CEO and president and
men he was a member of the top
decision-making bodies for their global
operations and products responsible for
advanced technology and product
portfolio capacity and strategic
planning he has been an RD leader who
expanded GM's rd to a global
organization with labs worldwide and he
is championed vehicle electrification
connected vehicles fuel cells biofuels
advanced batteries and many other things
which I think will hear about it so
please welcome Lawrence Prince
thank you very much can you hear me ok
I'm I'm hard of hearing i actually lost
my hearing 16 years ago and so it's
important that i come through clearly to
you you know living in the world of the
the hard of hearing has its moments eyes
up my audiologist recently and I walked
out with two other patients and the
woman next to me said isn't it windy and
the guy next her said no it's Thursday
and I said so am I let's go get a beer
and speaking of beer this is to fax if
you remember two things from my talk
golfers it turns out a golfer typically
walks 900 miles a year and drinks 22
gallons of beer that's 41 miles per
gallon which is about the efficiency of
a plug-in hybrid of a hybrid electric
vehicle which is which is pretty good so
here's what I like to talk about you
know as people who live in the United
States I think we realize we have an
enormous amount of freedom to move
around and to interact and it's just
essential to our economy it's essential
to our lives it's essential to creating
jobs and in fact ninety percent of our
movement is by automobile there's 250
million automobiles in the United States
they drive on 4 million miles of roads
and we drive them three trillion miles a
year refueling them at 170,000 stations
that's pretty daunting a huge amount of
inertia with respect to how we do it and
in fact the solution that we use is
about 120 years old so John I really
appreciate your framing comments taking
us back to the late 1800s because that
transformation on how we move around
occurred at the same time and the
problem we have today is it's not
sustainable it's not sustainable from an
energy perspective from an environmental
perspective but also very importantly
from a safety and congestion and
affordability and equality of access
perspective the good news is that we
have a portfolio of technology solutions
that are emerging that really promise to
address these challenges but for any of
those solutions to matter they're going
to
scale scale to an enormously large size
to compete with the solutions that we've
learned to accept and for that to happen
the markets going to have to scale it
we're going to have to have solutions
that people really want to buy because
the value that they realize exceeds the
price that they're paying and we're
going to have to have solutions that
companies really want to supply because
the cost that they can supply it out is
lower than the price that they can get
and when we can reach that market
tipping point with our portfolio of
solutions it's going to take off and
it's going to grow nonlinearly and it's
going to solve these problems and I'm
very excited about that but we have to
keep our eye on consumers first and
foremost no consumers of mobility have a
wide range of needs driving cycles can
go from driving around in cities to
driving between cities and duty cycles
can go from very light loads to very
heavy loads we have to accept that
there's not one way of moving around
there's a wide number of ways of moving
around in addition we also have to
recognize that we have to get off of our
nearly hundred percent dependence on oil
is a source of energy for our mobility
systems the good news here is that
biomass and wind and solar and very
importantly natural gas which are all
domestically produced resources that can
be deployed at very large scales as
alternatives to oil really hold promise
to provide plenty of energy to solve
these challenges but we have to mirror
up the energy with the vehicle that
codependence is extraordinarily
important now beyond energy and
propulsion systems there's also a very
important class of technology and that's
connected vehicles in fact we're at a
point where the historic DNA of the
automobile internal combustion engines
and oil and mechanical machines that are
controlled hydraulically and
mechanically that operate pretty much
standalone that new DNA has emerged it's
electrically driven vehicles using
electricity with batteries and hydrogen
fuel cells control digitally an electron
clay very very importantly connected by
connected i mean vehicles that
communicate with each other and
communicate with everything along the
roadway communicate with pedestrians and
bicyclists and when we bring these two
together and marry it up with what is
termed the mobility internet now this is
not just the Internet of bits of
information or the Internet of electrons
flowing in the smart grid this is the
Internet of atoms moving around and
managing that flow of movement and we
put the mobility internet with that we
really have a way to transform the world
what we're going to be seen our vehicles
that don't crash they're not going to
run into people or bicyclists we're
going to be seeing our vehicles that can
drive themselves and so texting won't be
an issue in fact many people would
conclude that driving is the distraction
rather than texting being the
distraction and then we're going to see
the opportunity because these vehicles
don't crash to reduce their mass
significantly why is this important it
just simply is not sustainable for our
bodies weighing a hundred to two hundred
pounds to be moved round of machines
that wait three four to four thousand
pounds we have to change that and one
way to change that is to leverage this
communications technology so cars don't
crash week a lot of mass out of the car
and change the physics of that whole
situation now if you're wondering is
this pie in the sky I'd like to take you
to today's World's Fair the one that's
starting on may first and Shanghai the
world expo and General Motors in
Shanghai automotive have a pavilion
there that will attempt to do much look
like what we heard about in Chicago and
it's showing a vehicle concept that
weighs about 750 pounds it drives on two
wheels it dries autonomously it doesn't
run into each other and we think the
future is within our grasp with that
kind of technology so I'm very very
optimistic about where we're headed and
I'm delighted to be part of the Earth
Institute on as I embark on my second
career it's great both finials can Jeff
Sachs reach out to me and this is just a
marvelous campus to be affiliated with
as evidenced by this event and I just
want to end with one
advertisement on Tuesday we're going to
have our first roundtable on sustainable
mobility which is going to begin to
focus with working with cutting-edge
companies on how we're going to bring
this transformation about as quickly as
it possibly can thank you thank you and
our next speaker is RT Krasner the way
these these introductions are long but
these people are very accomplished so
bear with you RT has his director of R&D
at four power supply at coned and he's
responsible for developing and managing
rd for coned as well as for orange and
rockland county utilities he I've known
already now for about six seven years
he's been really instrumental in and
have been the projects that being we
worked on a Columbia and has been a real
visionary about the area he manages
program developing technology for
electrical transmission distribution
control center operations substations
customer operations and energy
efficiency he's innovated a remarkable
number of remarkably innovative projects
for con Edison which you can see on the
wall of his of his area he recently
authored co-authored with Roger Anderson
who's speaking soon Albert boulanger and
John Johnson a book called
computer-aided lean management for the
energy industry on the application of
lean management principles to the energy
industry and in the interest of time I
will stop there but please welcome our
team
well good morning first I'd like to
thank the organizers of the day for
inviting me to be here and to get an
opportunity to speak to this group and
especially the students I think we're
into a very exciting time much like what
John described I think it's one of those
pivotal moments I've been in this
business for a long time and I'd have to
say right now right now is the most
exciting the most interesting and I
think going to be the most significant
moment especially in the energy industry
perhaps since Edison and that's a lot to
say from someone from con Edison first
I'd like to set some context of my
slides on this yeah okay yellowwood but
the the electric vehicle we see is as an
integral part of the smart grid as John
described it so it's all about the
components it's all about the nodes and
the the smart grid is is really being
driven by a number of changes that are
happening kind of simultaneously there's
the emergence of renewable energy in the
form of photovoltaics and wind power
it's it's getting more efficient lower
costs the problem though when you look
at the interconnecting lodge systems is
that it's intermittent and unpredictable
we need to be able to manage this we
need to be able to integrate all of this
customers are that have iphones and that
have all the technology worn choices the
just plain vanilla you could have any
color you want as long as it's black
kind of of choice just doesn't work
anymore so we need to be able to meet
our customers expectations electricity
is becoming increasingly vital both to
our personal and economic well-being I'm
bullish on electric
I think electricity is going to be
increasingly more and more vital and
important in being able to meet the
future that we're we're all hoping and
anticipating you know I'd like to say
that people don't buy electricity they
don't buy the product that I've spent my
career making and distributing they
really are buying entertainment comfort
health security they're making choices
and by the way in order to enable those
electricity is an increasingly important
part of that and the next choice that
we're going to see being transformed
this personal transportation and these
electric vehicles are emerging and are
really the enabler of the smart grid
it's the smart grid each is enabling the
other this is a very vital relationship
that exists between all these
technologies in the grid I'd like to
borrow from that conversation at genre i
had a while ago the the kind of metaphor
that John used to describe what's
happening just as I T has been the
fundamental underpinnings of a lot of
information technology has been the
underpinnings of a lot of the the growth
and the the innovation and continues to
be I believe that et energy technology
is the underpinnings and growth of the
future
are we ready for the electric vehicle in
New York City well first of all electric
transportation is nothing new to New
York City 110 years ago we had electric
delivery trucks parked alongside
fifteenth street at coned and we have
pictures to prove it so the electric
vehicles of binya but mass
transportation right now the subway I
got here on an electric vehicle and
that's the stand elevators vertical
transportation are the are the backbone
of the way we all move around in this
city so to New York City electric
transportation is kind of we take that
for granted I think that the vehicular
traffic in this city delivery trucks
buses are major major portion of what's
out there we do have personal vehicles
people do drive but the principle modes
of vehicles that are out in the city are
these fleets and those are ideal for
early adopters in electric vehicles the
charging infrastructure to drive those
the the length of the of the of the the
trips that those kinds of vehicles take
really fit extremely well into this
metaphor and there's a whole lot of them
and they do contribute to the noise and
the and the pollution in our city and
that would be a great great solution to
have also in New York City are private
those private vehicles are small to get
into those parking spots that we all up
for and they're used by and large for
shorter trips so they make a lot of
sense and from the viewpoint of the grid
I think we are him there I think that
there for all but a very few hours in
the day in the week excuse me in the
year the grid is more than capable of
meeting the requirements of the electric
vehicles for quite a bit of time
into the future and for those few times
that there is a there are issues I
believe there are innovations that some
of them were going to be demonstrating
in our smart grid demonstrations that
John and Roger will be referring to and
there and we need to get out of the way
and let innovation take place and people
will be coming up with solutions this is
not a problem that's insolvable i
believe it is very solvable so that
pretty much concludes the the brief
comments that I wanted to film in on
thanks Artie okay our our next speaker
is Roger Anderson I've had the pleasure
of working with Roger closely for the
last six years he's p I on all the con
Edison and DIY projects that have been
that have come out of the center that I
run Rogers been at Columbia for a long
time 35 years he's a senior scholar at
the Center for computational learning
systems at NCS Roger results as a
principal investigator of a group of
about 15 people who work on smart grid
related projects in my Center and he's
been working closely with coned Boeing
and others for the next generation of
smart grid technologies in the city he
was previously at lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory he founded a company called
borehole research a global basins and
for and did 40 seismic work starting the
company i think the week that oil hit
ten dollars a pound which was not good
timing so he came back to columbia
fortunately for us he also teaches
planet Earth which is a science
requirement course in columbia college
and he founded alternative energy
program at the School of International
and public affairs at Columbia and
finally he's director of the urban
utility center at polytechnic
Institute of New York University so
Roger how many of you know of Energy
Star everybody knows that I just wanted
to point out that already crest nur
invented it he's the originator hose
dragging on somebody other than myself
let's see I need to try to figure out
how to well I'd like to build on what
the first two speakers have been talking
about in terms of trying to understand
the complexity of this machine that we
are about to launch into in 1897 the
concept was pretty simple electricity
flows from the generation downhill until
it gets unimpeded to its customers
basically like water sloshes downhill
rivers to the ocean we're in the
fundamental recharacterization of that
pathway and electric vehicles are one of
the major drivers along with getting out
of this hydrocarbon economy and more to
what I like to call the electric economy
electric vehicles are mobile and they
carry the load with them and
consequently they change they and other
sources that are distributed like like
batteries big large batteries for
example that stand alone from vehicles
change the dynamics of management of the
grid the electric grid now will have to
have the capability of receiving power
and distributing power on all ends it's
not a first adapter or a last adapter
the first mile or last smile it's every
mile
and that is a very interesting
computational problem first of all and
it's an extremely interesting control
problem and if we are not careful it
could be a god-awful mess I think that
the thing that is driving us here at
Columbia so hard to participate in the
reformulation of the electric grid in
New York to what we call the smart grid
is the worry that if we're not careful
the lights are not going to reliably
come on when we flip the switch and John
Gilbert's elevators are not going to
routinely move up and down when push the
button and the little light comes on if
we screw this up we screw up global
economy it's sort of like launching into
a wall street that we just experienced
only in the electric grid and we don't
want to do that because we're not
capable of throwing the dice in this
kind of a world and hoping that we can
cope with the complexity it's a
nonlinear dynamic machine the world's
most important machine and if we ask
what are the problems that we have to
address I just have a few of them that
have impacted Columbia in particular the
machine is like a complex family of
patients and we in fact use here at
columbia technologies right out of our
treatment drug treatment and medical
profession there are pieces of it
failing all all day everyday components
of it just like people have knee
injuries and have to have heart checkups
and all of these things and when you
have a dumb machine one where everything
is just flowing sloshing around like we
had maybe up to about ten
years ago you over treat that patient
because you can't tolerate the failures
because as you well know and an electric
grid people get hurt and so we have to
we have to put introduce the
intelligence and this kind of a system
in order to control not only the
complexity of it but the fact that it's
constantly failing it's like the b-52
everybody knows the plane built in the
1950s still flies every one of those
planes is has zero components from 1950
they've been rebuilt and rebuilt and
rebuild modern engines modern control
systems that's how they stay up in the
air the electric grid is very similar to
that while there are still some
components of it that Thomas Edison
himself laid in the ground in the
streets of New York City there's not a
lot of those components and every year
we introduce more copper than we really
have to be able to afford in the city
there's already also likes to say it's
the largest copper mine in the world
right here underground in New York
introduced into that a million cars that
are electric and we really have to get
our act together about how to charge
them how to discharge them they're all
going to travel into Manhattan in the
morning they're all going to plug in and
move into John's from his apartment
buildings to his office buildings and at
night they're going to go back down into
the green garages in the basement and
they're going to go to the suburbs
transferring this massive load of
electricity that we are just now
figuring out how to handle in a in an
intelligent computer controlled
systematic way that's what
Thanks thanks Roger our next speaker is
a Jeffrey Sachs probably most of you
know him one of the most visible faces
of Columbia Jeffrey is director of the
Earth Institute he's court quite a lot
professor of sustainable development and
professor of Health Policy and
management at Columbia he's also been
special adviser to he is special advisor
to United Nations secretary-general ban
ki-moon and was advisor to Kofi Annan
before that on millennial Development
Goals and international agreed goals to
reduce poverty disease and hunger by the
Year 2015 he's also president and
co-founder of the Millennium promise
alliance which is a nonprofit
organization aimed at ending extreme
global poverty in two thousand four and
five he was named among the 100 most
influential leaders in the world by time
magazine sorry from Newsweek he was
awarded the padma bhushan a high
civilian honor bestowed by the Indian
government in 2007 he's a member of the
Institute of Medicine and as a research
associate of the national bureau of
economic research before Columbia was at
Harvard for 20 years last but not least
i should say i enjoy reading his
scientific american columns a club
Jeffrey thank you very much it's really
a pleasure for me to be on this podium
and I'm here trying to soak up as much
of the wisdom as I can from this
remarkable group because my little
nation this is to try to figure out how
public policy might help this process
along if this were mainly a matter of a
thrilling technology
on its own time rolling out I think we
would feel very confident that we're
going to get to where we need to get
with a very exciting new range of
opportunities for all of us here in New
York and for Humanity but the problem is
that we're operating against some very
very serious time lines that are a great
threat and what we're talking about here
not only should happen but actually has
to happen a lot faster than such a
complex process would normally occur and
that's why I'm listening to try to
understand if and how public policy can
nudge this along with the some alacrity
and some sense of urgency now I know
given the complexity of all of this that
there are certain things that can't be
forced and Larry burns is educating me
on the generations of technology that
will be needed to reach a certain of the
crucial tipping points that he spoke
about but let me talk briefly about a
couple of the other tipping points that
we face on the planet to frame some of
the importance of what we're talking
about today because of course we're
talking about not only the excitement of
new technological possibilities but
we're also talking about heading off
some extraordinarily dire risks that the
planet faces the transport sector is
roughly around a quarter of the
contribution of anthropogenic greenhouse
gases that are driving global climate
change and while we're all buffeted
daily by doubts of climate science and
by skepticism and by messages
not to worry and while we're in a
strange public environment in which more
than half of the American people don't
believe this is a challenge we at
Columbia are very lucky to be part of
extraordinarily rich scientific
environment science environment of the
world's leaders in climate science and I
can tell you what we hear every single
day is that this is a world changer and
we're just on the cusp of disaster our
leading climate scientists James Hansen
who is the US government's lead climate
scientist at the Goddard Institute of
space studies which is at 113th and
broadway and our guru wally broker at
the lamont-doherty Earth Observatory
both in their very distinctive ways one
from the atmospheric side and the other
from the ocean side and both from the
paleoclimate record carry one
fundamental message which is that the
climate system is profoundly unstable
nonlinear subject to tipping points and
that by all accounts of the paleoclimate
record as well as the physical modeling
of the climate systems as well as what
our colleges and agronomists tell us
about actually observed climate behavior
in recent decades were very very close
to highly nonlinear and highly dangerous
changes in the Earth's environment so
what we're talking about here is one
crucial component of addressing that
problem because the ability to move the
at least the light-duty transport fleet
around the world which itself will grow
phenomenally in the future years as
China becomes the world's largest market
as india's tata nano at two thousand
five hundred dollars sets a new
point and leads to wood tens and then
hundreds of millions more vehicles on
the road the challenge of finding a way
to benefit from personal mobility but an
environmentally sound manner is one of
the greatest challenges that we face in
the world and the possibility that
electric vehicles open up not only a new
Vista of the quality of life but also a
new Vista of energy systems that are
both environmentally safe and plentiful
is extraordinarily important of course
we're facing another somewhat unknown a
threat but one that is obviously
significant and that's the availability
of conventional oil which as Larry burns
said and of course as everybody knows is
the overwhelming energy source for the
world so that light duty fleet and I
think that it is fair to say that while
the debates about whether peak oil has
arrived or will arrive in 10 years or
will arrive in 20 years or will arrive
in 50 years is a real debate with a lot
of unknowns the security and
availability issues of our conventional
petroleum is a huge question right now
and I would argue that were in meshed in
war over that very question a very
stupid war in my view but a kind of
conflict that we're going to see more of
unfortunately unless we also find a way
to fundamentally alter our energy system
so it seems to me that we're talking
about something here which is
extraordinarily time-sensitive but also
extraordinarily complex we're aiming to
address a quality of life issue that
will be of importance for well over half
the planet very soon which is the well
over half the planet living in the
cities we are
dressing a environmental security issue
of profound significance and I think
we're also addressing indirectly a
national security and a global security
issue and that is how does a world
economy that's already pressing very
hard against the natural resource base
and in my view has already lifted the
real price of oil by a factor of roughly
three during the past ten years and I
think it's likely to stay high and
continue to rise how do we face these
challenges there's also a national
technological challenge which is the
very real point that were in some crisis
in our industrial and manufacturing base
in this country we are delighted to see
GM on the mend but we're counting on the
Chevy Volt to be the kind of new
leadership that can allow our national
industry also to play a very significant
competitive role in the world in the
years ahead and time is very sensitive
on that as well because our national
economy in my view is in crisis not just
a financial crisis but a technological
challenge let's say that is a challenge
of a much more competitive world than we
faced even 10 or 15 years ago because
our competitions coming from all sides
right now so to my mind the issue here
that I'm trying to understand as a
policy analyst and advisor is the timing
what are we what are we capable of
achieving in transformation to reach
scales that will make a measurable
difference on all three of these
dimensions on the environmental security
on the energy security on the national
security I would say is the second and
on the technological leadership
if we go along at the pace we're going i
purely by market forces alone my view is
that this will remain as many people
predict very important very fascinating
very exciting but from a scale point of
view a relatively small part of a much
larger and quite dangerous story so I
believe that we're in the business not
only of trying to find how to make all
of these complementary systems work but
do it in real time and do it in
accelerated time in policy time now I
just testified in Congress last week on
these issues and we're thrilled by the
way with our we we are already we were
represented by the the former head of
the Ways and Means Committee who's a
temporarily stepped aside and the new
one is our good friend a good friend of
this industry sandy Levin who called
these hearings but I can say what I
already knew beforehand and after
listening to the rest of the committee
knew very well after we have no national
policy on these issues at all we have
some important components where the
government is financing some technology
and batteries is looking for in
providing some incentives for the new
vehicles and is definitely interested in
these issues but to my mind we do not
have a proper framework yet that
addresses the realities of the
technological complexity the role of
public policy the role of infrastructure
the role of energy policy the role of
consumer realities and the role of the
time dimension that is involved in many
of the pre commercial and complex
complementary aspects of this challenge
the administration president said that
he wanted a million electric vehicles on
the road by 2015 good and specific goal
we don't yet have a policy to achieve a
goal like that or two and we've not
stated in I'd say yet a serious and and
national way what kind of goals we
should have 4 2015 4 20 20 20 25 20 30
and how we would get there we also have
the complexity of the international
climate negotiations because it should
be absolutely clear to everybody that no
matter what the United States does on
this unless there is a global framework
for climate change the world is going to
be wrecked and it's going to be wrecked
within the next 40 or 50 years and that
means that we need to take action now
because we're talking about
infrastructure and technologies that are
going to already be set in course for
decades to come and so the issues of the
electric vehicles are partly a national
competition issue but they're also
partly a global survival issue as well
that makes this very hard what is our
international policy perspective on what
we're talking about on the ways that
systems design sharing of technologies
shared concepts global goals global
standards should get integrated as you
all know and I know it very well sitting
inside the UN our international
negotiations are in disarray on all of
these issues one of the main reasons
they're in disarray unfortunately is
there is a complete disjunction between
the diplomacy of negotiations the
engineering realities and the private
sector it's as if it's three completely
different worlds and so one of the
things that also needs to be done is to
bring these worlds of the negotiators
the companies and the technology experts
together so all of this is to say that
I'm listening from a very particular
point of view
to the discussion this is an
extraordinarily complex system of
systems that we're talking about i think
everybody made that clear it is also i
and i share the view for all of the
important reasons both what is potential
in the technology for new quality of
life what is needed for the environment
and what is needed for global security
and energy availability we are at a
historic juncture we really are entering
a new era but it's not just entering the
new era it's not just being pointed in
the right direction it's getting to some
real destinations in time to make the
difference that we're going to need
thanks
thanks to thanks Geoffrey I've been told
we were running quite late so I despite
his many achievements I'm going to
shorten Tony poza watts's introduction
he currently this we finally get to the
vote right as the centerpiece Tony
serves as the vehicle line director for
the Chevrolet Volt he's been a gee gee
I'm for 25 years he's really pushed this
from day one I think he was employee
number one working on the volt and it's
been brought to market in a pretty quick
manner he's chairman a co-chairman of
the electric drive transportation
association and was responsible for
other vehicles like the Cadillac
Escalade and chevrolet avalanche so Tony
well thank you so much I want to first
thank Columbia University and their
affiliated partners for organizing such
an event for some of us in the corporate
world it's truly invigorating to leave
the offices the PowerPoint presentations
and being such a vital campus
environment and so thank you so much for
that it's it's good for the soul as was
stated my name is Tony paws wats sounds
like kilowatts but pronounced pazza
watts and it is true I do have an Earth
Day birthday so it was fate it was fate
that I'd be destined and dr. burns is
one of the people that helped influence
my appointment into the position of the
vehicle ID director for the Chevy Volt
so it is all coming together i think i
will talk a little about the Volt today
but i want to first acknowledge and
recognize my fellow panelist I've
learned a lot from them historically
I've learned a lot from them already
today but I will differ with them on a
few things here notice the man from the
gentleman company did not bring any
PowerPoint charts I brought a real
drivable car hahaha that's out of
college walk and it will be there out
till one o'clock today so if we do get
the opportunity
please enjoy some of the sunshine of
Earth week I like how it's changed from
Earth Day to earth week enjoy that take
a look at the car we've got some
technical experts there and I'll tell
you a little bit more about the story of
how and when the car is coming and it is
coming the other ways I difference with
my panelists is the following notice the
man from general motors company is the
one without the tie I have a short
sleeve shirt underneath here I don't
even have a t-shirt it's part of my mass
reduction program to be more efficient
had I only got a haircut before I came
here but I think the comments from the
panelists was were really wonderful set
up it gives you context about this
unique moment in history that we were
upon us and let me comment a little bit
an additional point in the timeframe
that was illuminated by our keynote
speaker and I used the term illumination
on purpose recently had an opportunity
to meet and spend some time with Daniel
Yergin who many of you know is an
esteemed author pulitzer prize for the
prize and so I read it intently trying
to learn about energy some of the
history where we came from I've done the
same with the history of electric
vehicles and and I think some of our
panelists highlighted some of the long
rich history of electric vehicles
interestingly enough in the prize
there's a fascinating quote from Winston
Churchill and it was really what spurred
I Daniel Yergin to call the book the
prize and it was something to do with
when Churchill was the head of the Navy
in the UK and he had determined what
fuel he was going to use to win his
battles he chose petroleum and he used
the term or the phrase mastery itself is
the price of this venture we've used a
little bit internally on the Chevy Volt
team to say technological leadership and
the ability to use technology and
innovation to solve our problems is
really what we're all about and as
identified by dr. burns and dr. Sachs is
a very very complicated problem but we
have history on how we've worked
together and solve problems like this if
you go back to the day and age when the
oil industry first began it wasn't
gasoline that fueled its growth it
kerosene it was touted as the new light
it created the ability for people to
read to become educated so on and so
forth we remember the oil wells in
Pennsylvania it was kerosene that was
first the product not gasoline
interestingly enough innovators and
inventors came up with something and
we've got wonderful colleagues with rich
experience and how the grid came to be
how Thomas Edison created the
incandescent light bulb and truly
created the new light replacing kerosene
and kerosene just like gasoline also had
its baggage there was many a small Hut
that was burned down and the like dr.
Sachs and I have talked about some of
these opportunities that some of these
innovation and technology could bring to
bear so I thought that context was
helpful because I think it's a very
unique opportunity as stated by my
fellow panelists I'm bringing so many
interesting winds of change together and
they intersect dr. burns is common to me
many times about something called the
power of an so let's comment a little
bit about six technologies that are just
really gaining momentum but the
synergistic effect of having them work
together is even more powerful and I'll
cite some examples with the Volt and
connecting it to the smart grid as well
the technology's there absolutely
fastening are obviously electric
propulsion and all that goes with that
motors power electronics systems
thinking integration software to remove
these vehicles advanced batteries the
chevy volt battery we'll take what we
typically know is the lithium-ion cells
in your cell phones I would venture to
guess most of those cell phones
batteries probably don't last more than
a year or two yet with the Volt we will
accelerate the robustness of the design
it will create a battery pack that will
last 10 plus years in a car and perhaps
another ten years outside of the car
talk about a leapfrog in the basic
simple cell that you find in your
devices
and operating an environment mind you
with temperature changes severe dramatic
humidity vibration one of the harshest
environments that exists so we think
that this is a significant technology
we're taking a leadership position I
with the vault and eventually will
understand a little more about the power
of an intersection how that helps some
of the other key technologies I referent
technology number three renewable energy
sources if we only could predict when
the wind blows and the Sun shines then
we could be waiting there with our
collectors right when the chevy volt
battery is plugged in hopefully 22 23
hours a day it becomes the ideal
collector most people are not driving at
night although I've had some strange
hours here in the last couple weeks that
have caused me to do that but
nonetheless that's when the wind blows
when you're at work during the day the
infrastructure opportunity that exists
to collect the Sun if you're just
plugged in and I know the people on this
campus are plugged in and we're going to
get you even more plugged in as we go
forward and we talk about the future and
when the bolt is coming to market smart
grid technology number four was well
stated by some of my colleagues how
important this is to eliminate waste
from the system and so much waste does
exist and we'll talk about how we can
make that a reality fifth technology
spoken to by dr. burns the connected car
and how our lives are connected I have a
fun thing that I do every time I'm on an
airplane and I sometimes chat with the
person next to me I've been known as
someone who engages in discussions and
conversations and I will place a bet on
them as to how many seconds it takes a
number of people that sit in front of us
in the plane when the plane lands to
turn their devices on to get reconnected
it's a very very powerful concept why
can't we now connect our cars to our
devices to our grids to our lifestyle we
have the technology to do that finally
six key technology of really fascinating
interest to me is also the engineered
fuel space where that the biofuel or
some other way
to integrate new fuels and some of the
wonderful innovations and ven shins are
occurring there so amongst these six
technologists multiple intersection
points let me comment only in a couple
of them with respect to all of your time
and let me highlight a feature that
General Motors has as it relates to one
of the fundamental strong pipelines
using cellular technology and this is
our OnStar wireless telematics platform
something that many you are familiar
with we've had it in our cars for the
past 14 years the vault will get the
ninth generation black box of onstar in
it and what does this allow us to do it
certainly allows us to unlock and lock
our cars remotely it allows us to deploy
airbags it allows us to connect with a
safety advisor it allows us to do a host
of other things under the fundamental
guise of safety and security now
recently I had an opportunity to go to
the OnStar command and control center
and umbrellas on center Detroit Michigan
and watch live the capability of onstar
applied to the next level what does this
mean we now have the ability not just to
remotely unlock and lock your car we now
have the opportunity when we're advised
of a theft of your car and the right
authorities are involved that we can
literally prevent a high-speed chase
locate that car and safely and securely
d power that car so that that criminal
can be apprehended by the authorities so
I was watching a video of this and the
thing that I found most intriguing at
the end is as the policeman approaches
the car there's obviously no power he
can't move he can't escape he tries to
open the door conveniently the doors
locked on him he tries escaping from the
sunroof and we closed that escape hatch
as well so what does that tell us as it
relates to the various technology
circles in the intersections if we can
stop a car from driving safely and
securely I think we can send a signal to
stop charging if necessary if we're at a
point in time in the middle of August
and three in the afternoon what we need
to shed some blow
as it relates to this technology that
just gives you a glimpse of the
possibilities similarly as we collect
data from OnStar from the car we have a
battery doctor on board we'll be
collecting more data just like some of
our friends on the internet collect data
and try to understand whatever ties
means you should be sent and so on and
so forth data is powerful and in a
university such as Colombia I think you
know and I'll understand this so it's
it's a very very exciting time when you
think that we do have the technological
pieces we do have the the problem
solvers to connect these dots to connect
the nodes as was stated earlier I think
that's very exciting so it would be
remiss on my part if I didn't at least
finish with a shameless advertisement
for the volt and I know you would expect
that so please adult Chevy old is here
today and we've been driving around and
engaging many a customer in the product
for the last six months or so very very
unusual for a conventional car let alone
a car that is so advanced the car is
being built today as we speak in
production flavors and what does that
mean it means the production version of
the car is at its home plant there are
production parts off of production tools
being assembled to ready this car for
the market to be launched at the end of
this year as you know it's been a well
publicized project and our launch date
has been advertised as November 2010 is
when we will build retail cars between
now and then we will have demonstrations
and we will squeeze out every possible
issue and bug that we can so this car
could be ready for the market and it can
be at your everyday primary vehicle and
be the first mass-market electric
vehicle and hopefully hopefully be an
enabler for a host of other electrically
driven vehicles whether they be pure
battery electric vehicles fuel cell
vehicles and be one of the great
integrators of all these technologies so
I'm sure you are rooting for us wishing
us luck we we feel we're on a very very
good glide path to deliver this final
thoughts
since the theme of this conference is
New York and the electric car we would
very much like to be bringing this car
to the Big Apple to the surrounding area
we have a do a project with con Edison
so they will be receiving some of the
very first cars later this year and
helping us make the car seamlessly
interact with the grid the new fueling
station and I know about you but i
really look forward to the day where I'm
my gas station will be in my garage and
I'll be gassing up my car in my pajamas
when I'm sleeping I really look forward
to that day and it's not far off so I
very much look forward to working with
you in the future I do believe that your
region and area is organizing itself to
be plugging ready the v's are coming the
Chevy Volt is coming and thank you for
your time thanks very much telling okay
at this point I'm going to introduce
Catherine Devaney who will then take
over for the rest of the the event
Kathleen is the deputy editor and global
business editor of Newsweek magazine and
she oversees the business and economics
technology coverage of Newsweek
including especially the green rankings
franchise for the magazine which created
as an annual ranking of the 500 largest
US companies she all she had worked
previously The Wall Street Journal enter
before that at Business Week magazine
and I'll keep it short but Kathleen
welcome
thank you very much I'm going to make a
few comments and then i'm going to ask
our distinguished panelists a few
questions few questions for each of you
and then i'll throw out a few questions
for the whole group and then i'm hoping
that you in the audience will have some
questions that you would like to put to
our panelists anyway I think we all know
that you New York is a very unique
transportation market for instance how
many people drove here today in their
own car anybody okay cameraman good
which is not to say that New Yorkers
don't have cars or don't drive about
forty percent of us own cars but we
drive differently than people in the
rest of the country and i don't mean
more recklessly i mean different times
we tend to drive on the weekends more
there are very different patterns based
on which borough you live in so people
here are driving but it's a different
place in many ways and okay i'm going to
keep talking and we garage our cars
differently most New Yorkers parked on
the street or in commercial garages we
don't have our own garages for the most
part which all of which presents kind of
unique challenges but also opportunities
for electric vehicles in this amazing
market but there's also a great need
because just like the overall figure
transportation emissions account for
about twenty-two percent of total New
York greenhouse gas emissions and
electronic vehicles represent a very
clear and obvious way to reduce those
and to help the city meet its overall
sustainability goals so even in New York
where we think of ourselves not driving
that much we have as much work to do as
the rest of the world doesn't reducing
those emissions now there's already a
pretty large group of New Yorkers who
are ready and willing to embrace
electric vehicles according to a pretty
recent study by the Bloomberg
administration up to sixteen percent of
vehicle owners say that they're ready
today to change their behavior start
driving electronic electric vehicles as
soon as they're available which is a
pretty large group and as Tony said next
fall will have the opportunity to
actually buy some commercial vehicles
and start start driving around so I want
to talk to our panelists today about
whether New York is really ready for the
electric car and what do we have to do
to get started on that and so I'm going
to start with Larry you talk very
persuasively about why we need electric
vehicles do we want electric vehicles
are consumers is consumer demand there
are we ready well that that's a great
question because if consumers don't want
them the technology won't scale and
we're not going to solve the problems
what's so exciting about the Volt and
quite honestly 29 other electric
vehicles that are going to come to
market in the next 18 to 24 months 29
you said 20 to 30 in total will be
coming to market over the next two years
what we're going to be able to learn is
what the consumers really want
technology doesn't happen in the auto
industry on one step typically it takes
three commercial learning cycles a
commercial learning cycle is the product
and the hands of real customers made
with parts manufactured by real
suppliers Tony said something real
important the Volt's now being produced
with production parts that were used
built with production tools right hugely
important step and so we go through
three cycles and we're going to learn
what customers really want and we're
going to understand what suppliers can
really deliver and that probably will
mature at about the year 2020 so I think
there are customers who are ready and
they're going to be our NASA astronauts
for this initial mission we're going to
learn from them and then we're going to
get more customers and more customers
than the thing will tip and that's what
we have to drive to what do you think is
the biggest psychological barrier to
getting people into this kind of car
range anxiety and that's why concepts
like the Volt the Fisker Karma are so
important because they've taken that off
the table right that's not to say some
of these other electric vehicles won't
have important learning opportunities
that do not have range extenders but a
customer simply doesn't want to make a
trade off on convenience and safety and
secure
and the use of their time right and so
if suddenly your inconvenience because
you don't have enough range or you're
concerned that you're going to be
stranded somewhere and you're going to
have to wait to plug your car around
that's just a real customer concerned so
I even more so than price of the vehicle
do you think well that's another
important issue the cost will come down
over time and the US government's
playing an important role to provide tax
incentives to get this started the
lithium-ion battery has a potential to
reach a cost target of about 200 to 250
dollars per kilowatt hour and we're
going to have to take the number of
kilowatt-hours down the Volt has 16
kilowatt hours and we're going to have
to take that cost of the battery today
which is significantly higher than the
two of 50 but we'll do that by learning
and so we have to stick with this I may
I'll be very disappointed if the story
is told based solely on first reactions
either overland overly negative right
we're launching an entirely new dynamic
we have to give it a little bit time
yeah we've got to stick with this way
off to learn RT it's a beautiful day to
day kind of hard to imagine August right
now but what about that hot August day
at three o'clock in the afternoon what
do we need to do to make sure that our
grid is stable enough at that point to
support the additional energy we will
need for electric vehicles well at those
relatively few hours of the year days of
the year right I think that there are
technologies we just heard about one
that onstar is developing so I'm
optimistic that those hurdles are very
solvable and the integration of
information with energy as the smart
grid is developed will alleviate that
problem so I don't see that as a
showstopper that kind of definitely not
so we're ready now we're ready now
especially in the early years we just
were hearing about the the cycles of
introduction of products right that's
going to take some time and uh that that
so you're saying demand additional
demand will ramp up slowly ramp up slow
roll of lease
right and that that learning experience
on the vehicles is equally important in
terms of the learning experience on the
grid and being able to be able to match
this demand it's not like we haven't
seen the introduction of new
technologies before right there's the
introduction of computer technology and
the implications is a Don on energy
growth and use of course are the air
conditioning in the 50s and 60s and the
electrification of the kitchen in the
examples take example so that so that
this is this is I think something that
that our industry is it seen before and
as responded and ran that's and that's
going to be our challenge right well as
one of the forty percent of New Yorkers
who do own a car at where do i plug my
electric vehicle in do we need public
charging stations and if so who's going
to be in charge of building them and
maintaining them uh yes I think that we
buy large do need charging stations and
John Gilbert mentioned one of the
opportunities he sees in his buildings
is providing charging infrastructure and
I think that this is again an
opportunity and Economic Opportunity
business opportunity for many people to
differentiate their services to create
new services to create value in in
different ways in garages in and even in
some public spaces okay great Roger
we're talking about marrying together
some extremely complex systems across
many disciplines what about the human
capital aspect of this so do we have the
proper are we training the right kind of
engineers do we need to think about how
engineers are trained differently
absolutely yes the system of systems
requires system of systems engineers and
that does not sit easily within silos of
traditional departments and
the talent will probably drive this on
the campus here at Columbia the most
active and most innovative energy group
is led totally by the students in fact
they're about the only ones who have
gotten sepa the school of international
public affairs to talk the engineering
school to talk to their tents to do
something they're the ones who are in
all of these organizations and I believe
that the force will will come from
students who want to do this for a
living okay it's it's like the early
days of the flower generation right
there's no what we'll call it we're
running out of letters XYZ generation
but we need a new kind of engineer
basically we needed we need a much
broader more more cross Lord trained
engineer than a specialist okay so when
we have those engineers and we're
working on the next generation of the
smart grid have we made the kind of
capital investment that we need to to
move on to the next level well I've been
talking around the country for a group
of seems to be being led by universities
I've been over to Arizona State and to
rice and talking to him about what we do
after the stimulus money runs out so the
smart grid is putting a lot of money
into New York City 370 million dollars
the largest investment by the federal
government in any city in America but
what happens after three years we
fundamentally believe there won't be a
follow-up from the Fed the feds you do
not believe they'll be a follow-up no
stimulus money is an extra appropriation
and it's doubtful that
that that commitment can be continued by
a department of energy for instance and
so it's really in our court philanthropy
+ @ + academia + industry and to sustain
this over the 20 to 30 years that will
take to put a million electric vehicles
into New York City I think that's what
Jeff is talking about great challenge I
believe it's probably one of a
government and policy rather than
technology right and as he was saying
also it's a place where we have to bring
the negotiators together so i just
wanted that i was once told an engineer
is a person who likes to work with
numbers but doesn't have the personality
to be in the countin account but but
from my own experience there is nothing
more interesting than what we're working
on right now right and we have to go
beyond interesting we have to get it
over the goal line we have to scale it
in the marketplace but this is really
exciting this really could be truly a
disruptive technology as we were saying
and the opportunities are at the
interfaces and that's why we need the
systems of systems perspectives and I
think the intra nears are gonna gonna
lead us elsewhere I really do okay
Jeffrey 8 and specifically when you're
talking about New York City if you can
bring it down to that kind of scale what
kind of health benefits can we see right
away from converting to electric cars or
or more to the point what level of kind
of penetration do we need to see before
we start realizing some health benefits
that's a tough question you know I saved
the hardest one for you well I mean that
Emma and I'm not not qualified to give a
thorough answer to that in in any way
clearly what we're talking about here is
not only the vehicle but what happens
and not just the grid but how the energy
is produced what that means for air
quality also for public safety as Larry
was talking about how the car is
actually drive and what happens to what
happens to the traffic flow so from a
public health point of view there are
many aspects of this there's the energy
aspects there's the traffic safety
aspects and so forth I think one of the
things we haven't really talked about
enough talk about how the grid can be
managed we haven't talked about the
challenge for New York and nationally
for what kinds of energy we really are
going to be putting into the grid right
and here the problem is pretty serious
in the sense that all these wonderful
alternatives which we all want all have
their own complex problems around them
we've not yet and I'm not up to date on
this but it's been very hard to get
agreement of communities to put in
upgraded to grid to the infrastructure
for example to carry renewables on
direct current because of bigger towers
and the communities not wanting to grid
to to pass through their area we've had
a difficulty with getting even a first
demonstration project of carbon capture
and sequestration which is another way
to clean up the grid there's a proposed
project in Jamestown New York and the
community says we love this technology
could you do with 5,000 miles away find
out how it works and then after a few
demonstrations so we'll have it here so
I'm pretty impressed on about the fact
that
we have so many complex pieces to this
that we've not really focused on I I
knew and we all know about nimby and we
all have come to learn about num be not
under my backyard with carbon capture
but I had not heard until last week
banana which everybody probably knows
but it don't absolutely nothing anywhere
anytime and where we are familiar with
that right the number of projects that
are now delayed on every kind of power
plant every kind of grid facility in our
country is very very large so it's true
in New York State it's true nationally
and this is where I think the political
leadership will be key to breaking
through some of these barriers right um
let me just step back and go global for
a second what is the role of EVs in
global development and sustainability is
this is this something that we're gonna
see being adapted in developing markets
and different ways or do you think it's
something that the United States will
pioneer oh I think this is incredibly
important issue because first of all the
world is now more than half urban to
begin with so we're talking about at
least at the beginning and urban
technology that is going to find a need
all over the world the world's biggest
cities by and large are going to be in
the developing countries in the future
almost all the mega cities third these
cities are building out their
infrastructure for the first time in
many cases and this is that's the
opportunity to get on a path that makes
sense and of course so we are seeing
we've seen this year China overtake the
US as the world's largest automobile
market and I think will never never see
the u.s. overtake China again because
that's a market that is subject to
phenomenal growth although it's such a
crowded country it really poses a lot of
questions about how many what kind of
automobile penetration in the
term all the experts here would know
better than I but in any event these
issues are absolutely fundamental
significance to the developing world
which is going to be the place where
most of the automobiles in the future
are sold and because that's where 56 of
humanity lives right now and so any
leader that one talks to these days and
recently spoke to the President of
Mexico about this and he's asking well
what about Mexico City as a place to get
started to city of 20 million people
with major environmental challenges and
extreme interest in this but you think
about China India Brazil this issue is
an absolute global issue and we're going
to face global competition no question
about it on who's actually going to come
up with with the models right right
great thank you Tony we've established i
think in earlier conversations and
listening to the comments that range
anxiety is a big issue for for consumers
so what how do I know when I'm on the
Taconic that my volt isn't going to run
out of power great great question and
it's been something that was referenced
previously that has been an anchor
around the technology for a long time
certain characteristics of battery
technology and one of the reasons
General Motors embarked on the Chevy
Volt is we felt the lithium-ion
technology and family of chemistry's was
a a nice point to build off of because
of it was increased power and energy
density so but it's been a a problem for
electric vehicles for the last 110 years
now many people are offering different
solutions for extending the range
because frankly as much as we hear about
many customers wanting to be green right
the green in their wallet is still
dictating their actions and behaviors as
such one of the ways that we have
constructed the Volt architecture the
propulsion system architecture and the
like is so that it can
create a solution to the range anxiety
exists with batteries that we know of
today there are ways to increase this
this range phenomenon there are multiple
opportunities for charging you can go
into faster charging you can go into
maybe changing out your battery you can
go into different ways to create
electricity on board the vehicle right
to extend your range the really key
point was from our perspective at
General Motors is that until you solve
the issue of range anxiety you would
never be able to make an electric drive
vehicle mass market because customers do
not want to make the compromises right
there have been electric vehicles for so
many years so many different attempts
and efforts and i'm not sure what the
largest single volume was but for
example the Tesla certainly it's price
prohibitive for many people I'm not sure
if they've hit their thousandth unit yet
or well if they'll ever go much more and
i recently read that the Roadster will
at some point in time move on to another
product move on to another line if you
will and it gets to larry's point about
the generations of learning right and
technology and in probing the market and
understanding the one thing I can say is
I have I have suffered from range
anxiety for as part of the new GM I
think we try to spend more time driving
electric vehicles not just our own right
but others I've driven the mini e here
in Manhattan before and I've not been
able to connect with a friend because he
was worried he wouldn't get back to
white plains and said we actually met in
Colombia vs down on the stock exchange
in a host of different vehicles so I
think you know kind of to the the points
made by the other panelists it has to be
consumer-focused it has to be stainable
sustainable from a business perspective
and you have to have a model to get
there and I think there are some nice
innovative technologies and choices out
there we believe the extended range
feature on the Volt today tell us about
the range of the volt and absolutely
right now we have high confidence that
the Volt will provide up to 40 miles for
most customers and this is completely on
or from the grid stored in your battery
seamlessly if your battery gets to a
point where you have consumed the amount
of kilowatt energy event of available
for use they're usable for the battery
to drive your 40 miles we seamlessly
turn on the engine generator set and we
can go without refueling or stopping an
additional 300 miles and so as dr. burns
indicated you now have the choice of
close to 170,000 fueling stations or I
don't know how many millions of plugs
there are but I gotta believe this quite
a few the vote was also designed based
on the size of its pack that you can
overnight with a simple portable courts
at 120 volt cordset we call it an EV SC
for the engineering students out there
electric vehicle supply equipment write
it down learn about it it's going to be
an important connector umbilical cord as
I reference from the transportation
sector to our friends in the utility
sector we can charge that vehicle
without special equipment or apparatus
overnight eight hours when you're
sleeping with a 240-volt you know
dropping your dryer outlet if you will
it's about a three hour charge and we're
going to anticipate people will get as
many charges and as possible hopefully
at your office or at your university of
the like dr. sex I think you have some
influence you can get a few charging
stations yeah and so the concept of
range anxiety is real we have some
solutions we think and I think in the
future other technologies will emerge
whether the battery or otherwise and I
think it's just the most exciting time
but I do really want to emphasize that
the range anxiety concept is real and if
you look at the sort of the the behavior
from from people if you know you only
had one hundred miles of range you think
that people are driving 80 90 miles no
they cut in half if you have variation
around that range as it relates to
temperature that decreases it more and
if the car becomes not usable are not
usable in certain seasons then I think
we've lost the battle we've lost the
battle because and this is historically
what's troubled the electric vehicle and
that he just didn't mean enough enough
people's lifestyle so we're going to
break through that barrier and as
as dr. burns indicated that we see a
many other vehicles coming and as as the
commercial goals may the best car win
right and how much will develop costs
the volt or never liked well where's my
PR guy we plan to announce our pricing
later this summer not even a range can't
give us any indication ality let me let
me comment here because I think dr.
Sachs really referenced some key points
as well in order to support the
technology during its early stages we're
very pleased that the federal government
and other entities are providing sort of
that cushion if you will to get people
interested in about the technology ok
the Volt itself is a Chevrolet right and
the desired state is to make it a little
bit more than a comparable compact car
so we believe when one compiles
ultimately the value proposition which
includes perhaps all the OnStar and
mobile app features the difference
between electricity and gasoline the
incentives and interestingly enough I
think there's going to be some very
significant announcement the next month
or two on the launch regions but
ultimately I think you'll find that this
car may be the equivalent of less than a
thirty thousand dollar car great so be
careful about the price I well quite
well that's what my answer was a little
lengthy no but you gave us a category to
think about and now i'm going to throw
out a question to all of you and then
ask for some questions from the audience
but again we talked about how New York
is such a unique market what's the role
for electronic vehicles in mass transit
or in the taxi fleet here how what steps
need to happen for that to move forward
obviously as art said we're we all rely
on electric transportation more than
many cities through the subway but what
has that what else has to happen here
art maybe I'll start with you since and
then I'll come back to you dr. Bernstein
um I i think the the point you bring up
about fleets i think that that is a
unique opportunity was speaking to some
of the folks who do package delivery who
I won't name specifically but they
specifically mentioned that their
Everage daily route in manhattan from
garage out to the route that they take
toodaloo the packages back to the garage
is a little less than 9 miles so that
kind of of vehicle use that's
interesting so local delivery local
delivery and so that that kind of fleet
the so delivery fleets taxis are a bit
problematic because they are because of
the cost of the of the medallion and all
our need to be out on the road there
doesn't seem to be much opportunity for
recharge really but but the idea of fast
charging and a battery swap outs might
fit that fleet well it's interested so I
and there may be other other technology
solution dr. ins yeah I want to go back
to the point I made about mass earlier
um actually a year ago I was in New York
City and we revealed a vehicle at the
time was called Puma personal urban
mobility and accessibility picture of
segue and widen the wheels and have two
people sit on it and cover it a vehicle
away about 750 pounds now transit bosses
64 passengers so it's 32 two passenger
seats two rows of 16 seats now picture
32 of these pumas following each other
closely side by side you can actually
move more people in those vehicles than
you can with the bus the 32 weighed less
than a bus so they're more efficient and
the 32 will cost less than a bus the key
is to redefine how we're moving around
and used the technology communications
transportation and energy technology the
convergence of that to change the game
the DNA of the car is 120 years old how
many industries are out there
that have 120 year old product DNA and
the reason it's 120 years old is there's
a codependence that's existed that fed
on itself so we need to change that
dynamic so I think there's a very
exciting future in New York City a
transit is great i'm not saying that
it's not an important part of it but if
we can move around without the taxi cabs
in New York City do a very quietly do
very politely so not running into each
other do it without any missions utilize
the electric grid but in this case
you're making much more efficient use of
the electricity all right three kilowatt
hour battery versus a 16 kilowatt hour
about around the vote so I think I mean
there's huge opportunities in the city I
do want to encourage everybody to pay
attention to what's going on in shanghai
at the world expo that the purpose of
that expose better city better life
they're looking at the year 2030 through
the lens of a mage or asian city and i
think not just for transportation
technology everything it's going to be
critically important and you can pay
attention to it not just by going there
but by seeing what you can get off of
the web it's going to be really
fascinating do we have any questions in
the audience let me follow that I'm
sorry one point that is that the thing
I'm most worried about in terms of
electric transportation in New York City
is the bad shape our subways are in so
you guys out there ought to think about
how you can help the MTA to modernize
the most efficient the electricity
transportation system that we already
have what does it carry five million a
day five million a day 24 hours a day
and it's in bad shape thank you yes sir
Vijay Modi had a question first of all
love the panel need more events like
this two questions one is we talked
about integration of transportation and
the building of the home today
seventy-five percent of end use in a
home is for hot water and space heating
nearly all of it coming from fossil
fuels how can that getting be taught in
an integrated way across transportation
and electricity as well so that's one
question the second question was in my
hometown in India they legislated that
all taxis be compressed natural gas they
are low speed they don't look that much
unlike the Puma but they are called
rickshaws and they get more than 100
miles a gallon equivalent if our grid is
going to come from natural gas before it
comes from a solar or wind what do you
think is the role of compressed natural
gas for vehicles let's start with the
first question he would like to take
that on ok can I just comment on those
figures for heating and how order are
using electricity that that's not the
case in New York City I'll get odd then
I misunderstood the question so so tell
me I'm sorry tell me you're questioning
the first question again could you
clarify the question was how can the
heating and hot water end uses which are
all fossil fuel derived from oil and
natural gas how can they be taught in an
integrated way across transportation
electricity and heat the panel was
addressing the integration of
transportation and electric and my
question is how did the third end use
which is for heat and you know yes heart
is brother yes there there are some our
future technologies that that go to that
kind of integration one of them is a
home fuel cell embedded in the hot wood
heater that creates electricity and
the waste heat heats the water and the
water is used for space heating as well
and then the electricity could be used
for charging a vehicle or for other uses
of electricity so there are appliances
and that have been developed that are
beginning to look at that level of
integration how about compressed
nationally oh yeah I don't think I'll
take that I'm really glad you brought up
natural gas 10-15 years ago the United
States was planning major ports to bring
liquefied natural gas into the United
States from Russia in the Middle East
because we are concerned we had a
shortage over twenty year period
technology has been developed called
hype hydraulic fracturing basically to
extract natural gas from shale deposits
of which of the US has four very large
shale deposits the reserves now the
United States for natural gas are very
very large and that's exciting because
natural gas is relatively clean fossil
fuel versus oil and vs col now there's
three ways you can use natural gas for
transportation you can compress it and
burn it in an internal combustion engine
you can burn it at a power plant make
electricity for a plug-in electric
vehicle or you can strip the four
hydrogen's off the carbon and make
hydrogen for fuel cell electric vehicle
so go back and do the calculations
engineers and ask yourself which will
you go for farthest on with a cubic foot
of natural gas putting it in a
compressed engine and burning it burning
at a power plant for a plug-in or turn
it into a hydrogen and in fact the
plug-in and hydrogen option are much
more attractive than the internal
combustion engine option there is an
application of compressed natural gas I
think that's going to make a lot of
sense and that's with them class 8
trucks and deliveries within cities and
things because the diesel engine doesn't
have a lot of good alternatives so I
think compressed natural gas can play
there and while I have the mic I also
want the engineers to do the calculation
if you have an acre or a ton of biomass
and you can turn it into ethanol or you
could burn it and make electricity for a
battery or you could turn it into
hydrogen which way you go far
is done and in that case you go farthest
with the hydrogen and the fuel so the
good news is we have a lot of biomass
that's non food based we have a lot of
natural gas and you can use each of
those three ways for transportation come
on there's a solution just sitting there
for us to be had on domestically
produced energy if we can get off the
oil and get on to electrically driven
vehicles and these other own options are
did you have something to add yes I
there currently are two or three
compressed natural gas stations in New
York City and the number is growing and
the principal vehicles that that come up
to that pump or taxi cabs and it's some
small trucks so the I infrastructure is
it is really increased what is missing
now is in is vehicles that are built for
compressed natural gas right now most of
those vehicles perhaps all of them are
converted conversions aftermarket
conversions of commercially available
vehicles so we agree that electric
vehicles aren't are one of several
alternatives compressed natural gas
biofuels and and others are out there as
well Roger did you have something yet
one last comment I was with Dow Chemical
as a city in Texas entire city called
Freeport which got 10 petrochemical
plants and we were talking about
transportation uses of natural gas it's
a tremendous waste to take natural gas
and propel automobile with one person in
it compared to making plastics that they
would take first claim i believe on the
natural gas and electricity generation
would take second claim and i doubt if
transportation is very high
up on that list good next question yes
I'm Jim motivala from the New York Times
and I do think one of the elephants in
the room which we haven't addressed is
the question of we are in New York City
here and most people do live in
apartment buildings and park their cars
on the street and I was talking to a
fellow from Kalume which is one of the
big charging companies and he had a BMW
mini e they told me took a month for him
to get approvals through the city
government to be able to get his
charging station because you have to go
through the city and you have to go get
the in seven specters come out the whole
process is very delayed this is for a
residential home yeah to have a charging
station or a garage and saw this is for
people who have garages it takes a month
to get that approved so we're looking at
people who parked cars on the street in
New York City where I imagine a tangle
of different agencies have jurisdiction
and one can imagine that this could be a
very prolonged process with that I'm not
sure we've totally worked out yet we're
sort of addressing this on the macro
level and I think we need to address it
on the micro level to like on the street
how do you charge your car I will we
charge our cars party can you I i I'd
like to second that observation and I I
think that unfortunately a professor
Sachs left that is a domain where policy
at a local level would be very
beneficial to be able to untangle that
that series of approvals that are needed
to get that that charging infrastructure
there's also the emergence of commercial
entities that are looking at that very
problem and and trying to figure out how
they could perhaps build in charging
infrastructure in the streets so just
I've it companies that we are actors
just like you see
that's right just like you see the
booths it at bus stops just like you see
telephone telephone booths on the
sidewalk that there'd be some
streetscape a system that would provide
charging infrastructure for vehicles
that are plugged that are parked at the
curb Tony what do you have big an issue
is that from element let me come with a
little bit Jim good seeing you by the
way thanks for coming from a volt
perspective we recognized some of the
administrative challenges associated
with that and that's why the Volt is
very much geared towards not special
apparatus but basically find the plug in
the wall and charge your vehicle
overnight now in big cities and
environments like New York that is
certainly a different challenge but I
harken back to the challenge in the
context of is it a technological
challenges in invention or is it an
organizational challenge I like to tell
the story when we first were questioned
and queried about our ability to make
batteries General Motors and I finally
told them the story did you know that
General Motors had batteries on the moon
because General Motors was the battery
developer and manufacturer for the three
lunar Rovers we also designed the
electric propulsion system in the
software for Apollo 15 16 and 17 it just
so happens that Apollo 17 the lunar
rover went 22 miles I don't know if it's
real world miles or lunar miles but 22
miles and unfortunately the program was
scrapped due to no recharging
infrastructure so point being is if we
can do these kind of technological
accomplishments this is a little bit why
we're here today I think this is a
little bit why we reach out to you and
share with you the progress we're making
this is sort of it takes a plug-in ready
community and I think Jim's point was
spot-on I mean if we can just cut
through the permitting process I was
with the David's and below yesterday
since the secretary of Department of
Energy and he says he wants to he thinks
if we can't accomplish that
at and sort certainly the New Yorkers I
know if they band together with with the
key leaders we see here today and the
thought leaders we hate to see around
the air I'm confident we can figure out
a way now remind you early on we won't
have that many vehicles so it's the
perfect time to start figuring out how
to establish a main charging station for
someone in most cases in the Midwest at
someone's garage in their home or in
place of work but it's a wonderful
opportunity and challenge for us to
collectively problem solve the gentleman
hi my name is Bruce link and I'm the
entrepreneur in residence here at the
Columbia School of Engineering where do
you see opportunities for creating new
jobs that could also help stimulate
economic growth here in the city of New
York let me start off a little bit with
my home state state of Michigan which
has been very very hard hit during the
last economic time and just give you
some factoids on what we've accomplished
over the last year or so and I think
given the the talent that you have here
and the resources the like I think the
the the other opportunities abound in
the last short period of time we have
invested over seven hundred million
dollars in the state of Michigan and
that has provided us a that's just for
the bulb just just related to the Volt
what that has done is it's spun off did
a little spin off industries it's
involved universities because you need
trained in talat individuals and you
need the software and connections if you
will so that includes a vehicle assembly
plant detroit hamtramck a brand new
battery plant in brownstown michigan
state of the art we've had two
investments in the state of the art
probably world-class battery laboratory
facility cell manufacturing facility if
you include beyond the 709 stin some
investments outside the company we're
creating a corridor you know a hub of
this activity what I would encourage new
york to do and i think you guys have the
wherewithal i've seen some great signs
of organizing your area you create a hub
of a plug-in readiness and then there's
a whole host of different
portunities whether it's solar panels on
top of the charging stations you know at
various venues whether it's places of
business whether it's small fleets I
think the learning exercise of
generating some of these little
initiatives will spawn other other
opportunities and I think the most
interesting opportunity is the education
and the knowledge base that you
accumulate those that move first in this
space I'm convinced well we'll think of
the next best idea and then obviously
get some benefits i personally think the
use of the battery and if you get some
familiar with using the battery and
charging it can do some wonderful things
as i talked about collecting renewable
energy i think at some point in time we
may have batteries in our homes and you
want to talk about an interesting
perspective that that provides and
affords us relative to having control of
your own energy so great question all
right I yes the the car increasingly is
was pointed out this is it becoming an
electronic device and software and the
intelligence and the development of that
software and the technicians and the
types of level of capability that are
needed for that that provides a unique
opportunity for education as well as for
the training for the train mechanics and
technicians the there's some great work
going on in the state and specifically
in New York City in developing advanced
battery technologies there's some
amazing technology I saw it at City at
City College so we see work and
potentially the materials that those
batteries are made of are available and
fabric could be fabricated anywhere as a
matter of fact it makes a lot more sense
to fabricate some of those batteries
closer to the use so beers I believe
this displaces jobs that are offshore
now in the production of the fuels that
we use now and brings them on shore and
New York City is is it
a great place for those kinds of AB can
you imagine the idea of what we're
talking about here of displacing all the
petroleum that we import with
domestically created and produced fuels
with the you know the new inventions
with the you know kind of the six
technologies I referenced and again the
talented individuals we have on this
campus in this state so I'm going to do
a little plug Pam Fletcher's he or she
is our chief engineer for propulsion
systems on the Volt and she has other
responsibilities and plug-in
technologies and hybrid technology so if
there's any engineers who are interested
Pam I'm sure she'll collect your resume
because again we are intending to grow
this business and to your very point to
create some green jobs out of this great
thank you Thanks question please my name
is Robert Sinclair jr. I'm the media
spokesman for triple-a New York and I
write the test drives for our magazine
car and travel mention the psychological
barrier of range anxiety with electric
vehicle would throw a couple others out
there number one charging times which
you kind of touched on the idea that one
of your competitors Nissan Leaf it'll
get 100 miles on a charge and then
conceivably need a six of seven or eight
hour charge would seem to be a barrier
and also performance you talk about the
unique driving environment here in New
York we've got a lot of poorly
engineered roads which mean you have to
accelerate very quickly to get in front
of that 100,000 pound big rig and it
seems that electric vehicles are pretty
much down on performance you know the
bolt has a sport mode i got to drive it
briefly and it seemed like it would be a
way to deal with that problem but most
part electric vehicles are pretty slow
and a couple of the things the batteries
that are going to be in these vehicles
what happens when it's time to get rid
of them are they going to be recyclable
with the lethality or the toxic or what
have you and with all these vehicles of
the future going to be connected and
talking to each other and not crashing
is our driver training program going to
be put out of business we are talking
dresses you guys want to him yeah I'm
afraid that one's coming to you Toby
great question i'm glad you had the
opportunity to drive the bolt so remind
me as we go along as on a couple of
those areas but let me start a little
bit on an area i know quite well
electric vehicle performance one of the
beauties about electric drive and this
comes comes right from the heart from
having driven as many cars as i've
driven is the delightful driving
experience if the vehicle is designed
correctly electric drive gives you a
couple of things the term instantaneous
torque sounds very technical but it is
very exhilarating anyone who's familiar
with gasoline-powered cars they work
their way up to a torque curve your
engine revving being at the appropriate
spot that's where you get your peak
power anna a vehicle like the chevy volt
an electric drive vehicle you get your
instantaneous torque immediately matter
of fact the vehicle you drove we had a
lag put in so you wouldn't burn the
tires our prototype tires so just so you
know even even even in regular mode the
Chevy Volt will be zero to 60 in less
than nine seconds and the instantaneous
torque will will have the feel of a car
that's maybe about a 250 horsepower v6
equivalent so if the vehicle is designed
properly electric drive and the
instantaneous torque is a wonderful
experience for managing the scenario
situation you referenced when I ask you
a question because I I too had a 65
Mustang and I know Dave and I would like
to have it make really cool sound you
got to put any kind of like false oh
well one of the things one of the things
that one of the things about the
technology we're talking about here and
all the software and the Vance nature of
it is you guys are familiar with one
point 0 2 point 0 3 point 0 and this is
why we come here so don't be surprised
if some future volts that one point oh I
offer you some of that that capability
so let's let's get back to it so what
about the disposal of batteries is a
different at present different issues
and conventional car batteries let me
let me kind of rewind to the comments I
made we immediately took the step and
saying take battery technology and
extend it and push it as far as you can
relative to lung
performance that gets the ability to use
the kilowatt hours of energy the
capacity as long as possible because the
technology is relatively robust based on
our testing of effectively millions of
electric miles on our cyclers and on the
roads so the volt battery for example if
you would consider 80 to 100 percent
capacity range we use a little over half
the battery pack that allows it to last
a long time it allows us possibly to
modify the state of charge window in the
future to give you consistent range
performance and allows us to extend the
life of the battery we also condition
the battery when it's plugged in it has
kept at a temperature we've we've
referred to the battery as our diva she
is temperature controlled she's got our
own heating and cooling system
liquid-cooled system and the very intent
is the longer you can extend the life
and usable life of the battery the less
you have to worry about recycling when
the battery after 10 years is considered
no longer automotive grade it still has
about seventy percent of its capacity
available and theoretically of will that
still be driven but instead of 40 miles
you may now get 28 25 miles and you just
use the extended range feature more so
we could drive it even longer so we're
we're pretty convinced and confident
it'll be 10 plus years in the car plus a
life outside of the car and then to your
final question as you look at the
covariance components the electronics
the metal the plastics and how you
extract lithium it is quite easily too
easily to recycle now there are no
large-scale commercial businesses today
that do that there will be there will be
what about the future of reducing
charging times again in a volt 240 volt
is a three hour charge the Nissan Leaf
you reference is an eight-hour charge
240 it's a 16 plus regular so we chose a
little less battery because it costs
less weighs less gives you more room in
the car takes less time to charge and if
you get an extra plugin you don't need
to have that really big battery so this
is the way we've chose the solution
there is some interesting things and you
know you might want to comment on fast
charging because I think that's a
technology there are several other
options and again realizing this is a
one point 0 tech technology the high
voltage 440 volt level 3 as it's called
charging though that has a very
significant impact on the grid so it
requires a kind of an intermediate
storage DC storage usually and that it
allows for recharging within 10-15
minutes is the kind of the kinds of
design basis and for that for that kind
of a system also there are other ideas
of creating battery packs that could be
swapped out so the car would be
equivalent to a being gassed up at a
pump there there's also the kind of use
pattern studies that a need to be done
typically a car might be used an hour or
two a day so depending upon the
pervasiveness of recharging that leaves
a 22 or 23 hours to recharge so with six
hour charges not at all I'm not
unfeeling it's a matter of fact it fits
very well but that would require pretty
pervasive availability of places to
charge so the this whole question of and
what the leaf people with the Nissan
people told us is that that hundred mile
range is is something because we as the
same question that hundred mile range is
really a covers a huge percentage of
people's driving patterns and what they
found was just the availability of even
a very few one or two or three charging
stations in a downtown area alleviates
the psychological anxiety it's not a
real issue it is an anxiety so that as
drivers are more used to that kind of
of fuel and adjust their thinking that
that's less and less of a problem in
Manhattan I have range anxiety every
time I bring my car in because there are
almost no gas stations so so that I saw
that that's the the challenge of we see
I I think you could tell your membership
at I'm being one of them that I think
that this is something that's that's
going to be a lot of fun to drive I've
driven a bunch of these they're terrific
vehicles I wish these guys well in and
and I wish them success both from the
viewpoint of I like the drive and it's a
it's a terrific car but also that we
happen to be the electric company and we
have no intent of eliminating your
driver programs trust me one last point
on that then already could correct
correct me but the city of Paris that
the the city government is putting in
the charging stations yes Kenny any sign
the New York City my administration
might be something like that now not you
know Thank You the last question please
I came a few minutes late so hopefully
this hasn't already been covered but
looking at sort of municipal charging
stations or private ones I was wondering
maybe already but notice if there were
companies like better place that's going
on in israel and i know i think in
denmark if there are private companies
like those that have been in
conversations with you or that we can
see the seeds of you know swap do
program going in already and my second
very quick question was if there have
been any either municipal or company
fleets or things like programs like
Zipcar that have put out with the
potential initial commitment to get us
from the early adopter phase to bring
this up the scale if they're happen any
sort of commitment
company fleets question the first
question uh there have been at least
three commercial suppliers of charging
systems that have gotten to speak to us
and describe their plans they are very
interesting very different approaches
better place being one of them and
they're just trying to figure out what
would make sense for New York City and
we're working with them they try and
help them the other is is uh the other
question in terms of municipal it hasn't
been any fleet commitments for all
companies or maybe like car rental not
leave you know places that would have
the infrastructures maybe already in
there lots were like is you know zipcar
or something where they could already
you know people might be using them for
short amounts of times they would have
that right the way I understand Zipcars
is that they park in commercial
facilities so they would and they would
engage in in in some arrangements with
those and it would seem reasonable that
they would do that there have been a
number of fleets that that have
approached us that were planning our
some stage of planning of putting in
charging infrastructure at their
facilities where they would have a fifty
or a hundred vehicles that could charge
so those conversations have started I
wouldn't characterize them though as
serious they're just exploratory so
there haven't been any sort of initial
commitment like ambition as the parking
garage people who owned a large perfect
those well I can't specifically say who
they are but the first one the first one
we talked about public yes we have had
three significant providers of parking
that have approached us people who own
fleets it's more exploratory stage thank
you did that answer question I don't
know I guess I was sort of looking for
names but I'm now for now
yes but it's it's it's it's the and
these conversations started about a year
ago so and I know there's there they're
thinking in their levels of commitment
are are serious and as they see the
vehicles coming to market they're
looking to be early adopters they want
to differentiate themselves and and
create a marketplace and I think this is
all going to be happening very soon
thank you well I'd like to thank all of
our panelists very much you've been
great today and I want to thank Columba